[Music]
we've scoured the city for the hottest
new fitness disciplines these are the
workouts everyone's talking about
we've got turf set white eye tabata yoga
and boot camp it's your body
this is fighting me I am Noah I
[Music]
this is your three-minute bootcamp leg
workout alright guys so today I've got
Noah here with me who is going to run us
through a bootcamp leg workouts whoo
let's do it all right so we're gonna
take it first you got it you've heard of
a squat right yes all right so we're
going to change the tempo of the squat
and make it a little bit more beneficial
so first move one minute long we're
going to square our feet up slow
negative so 4 3 2 full range of motion
ask the heels if you can or ask the
grass as they say just as high and up a
next minute move we're going to go in
for a back lunge with a hole that's it
we're going to add a little bit of a
pulse
30 seconds in switch legs then it's
going to get a little cray a little bit
okay a little bit quick we're going to
end on a high-intensity segment so right
here we're going to take it to a touch
up keeping all this weight up on those
heels power up onto the toes or get
those knees up high so you can go go
into a squat jump or a true tuck jump
which is it's a little bit higher impact
on the knees so 30 seconds of that
second high-intensity plyometric portion
popcorn squats nice and wide we're going
to work some of the lateral muscles
right here get nice and wide nice and
deep so this can all be done besides the
Tuck jump weighted or unweighted I'm
going to go let's shoot a form
bodyweight only run me through this man
we have one minute nice and slow three
to down all the way up now I want you to
really work your full range of motion
all the way down that's it so the most
benefit is going to come once you hit
that knee line in below so if your hips
allow you to do that want it nice and
low now squeeze your glutes as you rise
up take this right back into that static
lunge hold we're going to hold it once
we get our proper positioning knee is
right over that heel we're going to take
it into a little pulse just pushing off
that heel that's it we're going to try
to get a 90 degree angle from that back
of your hamstring to your calf perfect
keep it engaged 15 seconds now we're
almost quadrupling that time spent
engaging that muscle excellent muffin
top
so this is going to target that lower ab
region as well nice now-ish is going to
get real so let's do this 30 seconds on
the clock
tuck jumps so explode fast explosively
soften those knees as you come down get
those knees up to your chest as high as
you can
perfect try get those hands up a little
higher so you can really get some ab
involvement that's it perfect Oh
squat popcorn style so jump feet
together once you get the form down you
can play with the intensity in the
repetition speed to play with that heart
rate a little bit more deep into those
heels power up 20 more seconds throw
your heart rate a little bit still on
legs are coming alive we got no more
time okay again so to recap this is your
boot camp leg workout start off with a
minute of slow negative squats going
into 30 seconds per leg of the lunges
with the pulse 30 seconds of high knees
or as you call them the tuck jumps tuck
jumps and then you finish off with 30
seconds of the popcorn squats that gives
you your total lower body or leg
bootcamp workout this is tough just tell
me thank you
Norrell frenzy make sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any other fighting
weight episodes
you